à à
ừ ừ
anh
alo chào các bạn
alo alo
a
merry kỹ lại thì hôm trước
hôm trước buổi I
từ buổi đầu ra Switch có vẻ rất đông
không bị không biết được hôm nay nó sẽ
như thế nào nhưng mình tin là
Ừ nó lại giống như mọi hôm thôi đó là
mấy ông kia vào sen tò mò xong rồi cuối
cùng thì mất tích ở
Ừ
nhưng mà ở cái này bây giờ vẫn đang
trong thời gian tâm sự vậy nhỉ Mình tâm
sự một đôi chút được ạ
Ở mình vừa
mình mình không biết mình kể các bạn
chưa đó là mình có học liên thông
Ừ ừ
À ông Trường đó mình sẽ không tiện nói ở
đây nhưng mà
tưởng như là mình đã từng nói các bạn đó
là học không quan trọng với cái bằng cấp
lắm đây mình 10 lưu lại một vài ảnh cho
các bạn xem luôn cái anh ấy mình đặt tên
nó Min đấy
Nghe đài thứ nhất là
cái ảnh này lấy từ trang tôi đi Quốc đã
phải à
em à Đang chung kết thế giới thế gì còn
hôm nay còn mắng nữa
cho tôi tôi không xem là lâu nữa thông
cạn tôi bị hơn một năm nay tôi không còn
cầm tình về cái game này lắm vì nó cái
điệp khúc thật Điệp lãi
Ừ
thì tôi mình Mình vừa mới lưu lại hai
cái ảnh này một cái ảnh đấy
Ngày ngay Ti có gì giỏi đâu mà cần người
giỏi không ạ một cái thì là cái này
một điều lưu từ trang Tony có dạng u
Ờ Ờ
cái này đại khái Nói tóm lại là kiểu
quan trọng về kiểu nhái tin này quan
trọng về kiến thức để mà đi thực tập rồi
các thứ thứ thí nghiệm cái thứ hơn là là
kiểu bằng cấp nhưng mà mình lại đang
mình vừa nói là mình đang học lên hông
ra chỉ cần là hai ngày cuối tuần thôi
nhưng mà
đi học nên thông ở Quốc để lấy cái bằng
bằng đại học mình từ nói là mình cao
đẳng nghề mày không ạ
thì tại sao lại phải cần lấy cái bằng có
cả để vì thực ra là
về sau mình vẫn muốn quay lại đi dạy
rằng ạ Không phải đi làm đây nhá Đi đi
làm ở những công ty mà nó yêu cầu bằng
cấp thì mình càng thích chứng minh là
mình không cần bằng mình vẫn có thể vào
được công ty đấy
3 - công ty ở nhà nước thì mày là khó
nhưng mà còn công ty khác thì không quan
trọng quan trọng người mình kinh nghiệm
cái thứ thôi Ờ
Ừ thì khi mà đi phỏng vấn thì các bạn
khoe bằng cấp ra thì họ là là thứ mà họ
sẽ nhìn sau cùng khi mà họ không có việc
dinh Thịnh nhìn trong cái seri các bạn
bé lý do mà các bạn để C gần đây nhất
của mình ở chẳng có đề cập thì học ấy
Ừ thì kệ Nhưng nhưng mà nhiều cái sim đi
đấy rất nhiều người có thể inbox mình
hỏi
rất nhiều hát ở từ nhà Tuyển dụng bó hỏi
là kiểu muốn về là mày có thứ thứ không
khi họ họ có thể nhìn qua trình độ năng
lực của mình không cần qua một cái bằng
cấp gì
- 1h r1h ở rất buồn cười Tự nhiên hát
lời Hỏi CP của em trông chống trả Thế
kiểu à
anh em có thể nói qua một tí đó chị là
em tự học ở đâu không giống như kiểu để
mà gỡ điểm ấy và nghĩ rằng là mình mới
vay mới ra trường anh Bởi vì lúc đầu đọc
thì đọc nhầm tưởng không phải tự mình đi
dạy ở cây trường kia mà mình học ở
trường đấy mới ra trường ấy
chị là buồn cười vậy
I have have III nhá Không cần nhìn bằng
cấp nhấn mạnh lại họ Cùng lắm chỉ cần
nhìn xem thứ nhất là kính nhựa mày thứ 2
là ông biết thì anh càng tốt để mà Bây
giờ làm công ty nước ngoài thì nhiều kết
nối công ty nước ngoài nhiều
à à
ừ ừ
ờ
ờ bà vừa nãy mình mình nói là mình học
lên Hồng cốt để mà cậu về sau mình đi
dạy lại thì ở đại học chính quy thì họ
vẫn cần bằng bằng Đại hạ bằng cử nhân
hậu chữa thạc sĩ để mà đứng lớp dạy
Ừ nhưng mà tiện đây mình cũng xin nói
cái này đó là đấy thì cái vụ mà mình đã
hợp lý thâm như này và mình cũng học ở
mình cũng
Em Khóc Làm biết qua một vài trường đại
học dạy ở
Lập trình đền hình à Hôm nay mình còn
học lập trình web này
khi nhìn thấy các thầy cô đấy Dậy có vẻ
rất là kiểu
mình khẳng định là có thể cách cách thầy
cô ấy dậy có thể làm nhão hơn của mình
nhạt nhẽo phải dùng từ nhão thịt Bởi vì
các thầy cô chẳng có ví dụ gì cả câu
thầy cô ấy chỉ nói lý thuyết khá dài hở
việc là
không quan tâm đến sinh viên lắm không
quan tâm sinh viên kiểu có đàn tập trung
nghe không có đang hào hứng có Giang
thích thú với cái việc mình đang dạy
không khen mình mới phải dùng từ là nhạt
nhẽo Bởi vì các thầy cô ấy
Em đang dạy cho có chứ không Không hẳn
là có cái tâm của người dậy
cho mình và mình vào cây thầy thầy cô
lấy còn vứt vứt cho sinh viên bọn mình
cái kênh kênh YouTube để mà vào xem của
họ kiểu để câu như vậy kênh đấy cậu
hơn 100 nghìn lượt xem
ở Châu Á
em dại dại rất là chán ấy một cái bài
một cái bài hát Hà Tĩnh mà Lờ kéo dài
mười mấy bài xong rồi cậu nói cũng mông
lung kiểu gì sẽ như Cực
Ừ đấy thì mình mới cảm thấy à Cậu sự thì
nhiều lúc mình muốn lá vào đại học chính
quy để mà dậy để mà
biết đâu Mình có thể
cứu phải dùng từng cứu bởi vì có nhiều
bạn
các bạn bè của mình Minh Minh bảo rồi
Mình không học đại học chính quy nên là
mình không thể khẳng định được việc chất
lượng dạy của họ như nào ở phía sau khi
rét và có nhiều người quen với kiểu dạy
đấy thì đúng nhưng
Ừ mình vẫn thấy là có rất nhiều bạn bè
của mình học đại học chính quy
đại học Bách Khoa loa nhé
bạn đấy làm bạn để bỏ cái ngành này cho
dù bão từng đam mê giống mình
đã từng đam mê dù mình chẳng qua là hai
người học ở hai môi trường khác nhau
vì thế mà cuối cùng thì bây giờ thì mình
có vẻ khá là ổn khá là ổn thôi còn bạn
đấy thì Bỏ hẳn
Cho mình hỏi tại sao thì bạn ấy bảo là
học trên trường rất chán học và chiến
trường làm cho tao kiểu nhụt Chí Hơn vẫn
Vân Vân Vân Vân Nam mình cảm thấy kiểu
thế thì say mất rồi đôi đổi đời với mình
quan điểm nhé cái việc dạy học ở đại học
đúng là tự học vẫn là nhiều
Chị chuẩn là phải dạy cho các bạn kiến
thức tự học đương nhiên là mình đang dậy
các bạn theo kiểu là cầm tay chỉ lỗi
nhiều quá Thực ra nó không tốt cả vẫn
phải dạy các bạn toàn bộ cơ bản thì các
bạn tự học nhưng
Ừ nhưng mà sẽ truyền được các bạn cảm
hứng để các bạn có thể tự họp có thể
muốn học nhưng mà đây là không không
chuyển được các bạn Cảm hứng mà còn làm
cho các bạn nạn đi Đấy là size của Mục
đích dạy đại học tối có điểm mình ở thế
các điểm của mình đó là đại học thì
khác với Tiểu học với trung học đó là
kiểu đôn đốc từng bạn một rồi xong rồi
Kiểu giỗ rồi kìa em ơi là mày đi rồi
kiểm tra bài không để học chuẩn đấy nó
là kiểu dạy có vào tiền thức cơ bản có
kiến thức chuyên sâu và cư truyền các
bạn cảm hứng và Ai thắc mắc gì thì hỏi
còn không thì chủ yếu vẫn là tự học anh
Bởi vì đây là cái nhàng cái nghề đó bạn
các bạn học để làm theo cái nghề này chứ
không phải là đại học bây giờ là kiểu lý
thuyết thì quá nhiều
màn những thiết thừa cũng quá nhiều thừa
ở đây ấy chỉ là
anh một lúc dạy cho các bạn Ok thì đúng
là dậy rồi các bạn 3 4 ngôn ngữ lập
trình để các bạn tự chọn cũng được không
sao nhưng mà
anh không hướng rồi các bạn một cái gì
đó để cho mà sinh viên năm 4 năm 5 vẫn
còn đi
anh vẫn còn chưa biết tương lai mình sẽ
như nào đi thực tập Sẽ như nào vẫn vân
vân bên trường mình ý định hướng về việc
đi Được tập ngay từ đầu năm 2 ngày nào
cũng nhắc đi nhắc lại với sinh viên với
việc đi thực tập để cho đến cuối năm và
đi thực tập thật
27 nghĩa là chuẩn là như thế
các bạn trên nhắc đến từ nước ngoài nước
ngoài kể cái việc dạy đại học nước ngoài
nó còn rất hay như thế này nhé đó là đã
học của mình đang bị kiểu mình mình ăn
mình hình như mình bị Rập khuôn trong
đầu là ai cần có cái bằng đại học đấy
còn bên nước ngoài sang hoàn toàn nhé
bên nước ngoài thứ nhất là tiền học phí
của họ rất đắt đại học ấy các bạn hiền
như toàn thấy nợ rồi
gì để mà thực sự là các bạn muốn muốn có
muốn có cái bằng thật muốn muốn học đại
học thật thì các bạn sẽ phải
chị sẽ phải rất là chịu khó và sẽ rất là
tốn kém nó sẽ cho các bạn nợ nhưng mà
các bạn sẽ phải đi thực tập đi làm để mà
chả thấy cái nợ đấy những thành ra ở bên
bên nước ngoài thì chỉ những ngày nào
thực sự có nhu cầu cần và thực sự thèm
muốn theo thì mới
em mới học đại học
anh ở bên nước ngoài như thế
Vì thế nên là và bên nước ngoài nó sẽ
càng ngày càng cố hướng đến thực tế nghề
đang có gì nhất mình xem đại học ở bến
nước ngoài đứng nghĩa là công nghệ họ có
thể hơn nhé Thành ra họ đang dậy bị cáo
này xong dậy ai Cái thứ B gần đây thì
trường đại học mình mới có nhưng mà vẫn
kiến thức Hà Lâm quá còn ở bên ngoài
thực thực tế rất nhiều rất nhiều luôn
Làm hẳn dự án được thế rất nhiều mang
tiếng là đã học chứ hỏi ở trường Cao
đẳng nghề đâu nhé
ý nghĩa bên đấy ăn Dậy đúng cả làng nghề
nhiều hơn con bên mình thì
anh
vẫn bị phải đến quá nửa học đại học là
theo phong trào theo kiểu lại
Lý do là
dòng họ em ai cũng học đại học rồi đều
có cái bằng đại học bây giờ em kiểu gì
phải có sẽ nặn Thế có rỡ là em không
thích học đã học em thích học nghề nhanh
để đi làm chẳng ạ ạ
Ừ nhưng mà nãy giờ mình đang nói còn
những cái vấn đề nó hơi bị
Ừ thứ nhất là nó nhức nhối sẽ chắn bởi
vì đến bây giờ nó vẫn đây nhưng mà nó
hơi bị nhạy cảm thì thấy cha mình tạ
thôi
em không mặc bay kênh Ừ nhưng mà
thì mình nghĩ là nãy giờ mình nói không
có tí gì xinh ta cả cái nên thành ra
Chắc không sao đâu Hoặc là mình chưa nổi
để mọi người biết đến không ạ ạ
anh không kịp kìa
bố mẹ bố mẹ các bạn thì mình không biết
con điểm nào nhưng mẹ mình thì từng là
một người mà kiểu
đến cả Chín Nghĩa mà còn đánh mình
anh đòi 10 cơ tại sao mày không được 10
rõ ràng là cái này mày làm được như là
do mày Vân ơn ai bây giờ xz mày mày chơi
mà chủ quan nên mày mới chỉ 9 thôi đấy
có sư thứ nói chung và mẹ mình con người
làm cho mình rất là cầu toàn
Nhưng mà khi mà lên khi mà lên cấp 3 khi
mà gần thi đại học đấy Mẹ kiểu khiến
mình ra thoải mái theo kiểu là thực ra
mẹ mình không quan tâm mình được mình
chưa thay đổ đại học luôn không quan tâm
mình học trường nào thật chứ không học
đại học cũng được mẹ bà là bây giờ Mày
đủ tuổi chín chắn rồi mẹ chỉ còn mà chỉ
cần mày nên người mày Cậu biết nhận thức
được cái nào đúng cái nào sai kiểu nói
chung là trở Hạnh con người
anh là được mà dùng từ chợ thành con
người ngày ăn Chị ạ kiểu một con người
cậu biết phân biệt ở đúng sai hướng
thiện cái thứ thứ
em không cần phải kiểu
em có rảnh phải cực kì vọng Giang Cái gì
đó phía sau mình chắc là mình sẽ giận
con mình như thế không Không đến nỗi là
cậu ép con cầu toàn nữa mà mình không
ngờ mong con mình thông minh mình mong
con mình biết từng nhân xử thế và nên
người thế không thì tôi sẽ dần nó ra đã
à à
ờ ờ
Ok nói chung à
ạ bây giờ bắt đầu buổi họp ở Nhật
từ hôm nay thì ở mình đầu tiên mình trả
lời câu hỏi này nhé
Đây thì có hai bạn hỏi thỉnh thoảng mình
thấy rất nhiều Bạn thử hỏi cái này mà
mình nhắc lại lần chờ đây nhắc lại lần
cuối đi à
ở đó là mình sẽ không không quan tâm về
cái ngôn ngữ Lập trình là gì lắm giống
như bạn kể này hỏi về java này rồi dẫn
chị Ruby VP này Mẹ từng nói rồi mình
không quan trọng với ngôn ngữ lập trình
lắm đương nhiên là bây giờ mình đang
chuyên về TP thì mình sẽ dạy các bạn
được pê đúng ạ Các bạn học các bạn thấy
nó dễ học thì các bạn học thôi ông ạ và
về sau các bạn mới nhảy sang cái khác
thì vẫn được nhưng mình nói rồi nó vẫn
dễ Ngày Nên là các bạn không Không phải
kiểu
thấy ở đây không dậy Lara không họp nữa
tìm nơi Họ dạy ra đi học không Không cần
phải như thế
Ừ ok
a tiếp theo là
từ hôm nay mình sẽ dạy các bạn về vòng
lặp không ạ
bằng Nạp và tương tác với cái input đầu
tiên vòng lặp lại cái gì đây mình sẽ mở
em xóa hết kodi vậy ạ
ừ ừ
à à
à à ừ ừ
ở đầu tiên là về phòng học thì các bạn
hôm trước các bạn biết về cái vụ shipper
rồi đúng ạ Các bạn biết được vụ Kiều Nếu
đúng thì làm gì và không thì làm gì rồi
đúng ạ Nếu mà còn về có mặc thì như mình
đã nói cái cái thế nào lập trình nó nó
nó nó là liên quan đến về cái điều kiện
tiếp theo
và thứ hai nó là vòng lập lúc
thì mình mình sẽ hiểu cái bản chất cái
nút này thì ra nó ra ít theo thôi là nếu
đúng thì tiếp tục chạy còn nếu sai sẽ
dừng lại đấy nó là như thế
máy tính ấy thì nó sẽ hiểu Ừ nếu các bạn
nghe qua là phụ máy tính là nó sẽ hiểu
mã nhị phân Thôi đóng ngoặc là một phải
không Tức là một thì nó sẽ nở đúng nó sẽ
chạy còn không này nó sẽ nó sẽ ra Cậu
sai và nó sẽ ngừng kiểu thế Còn vòng lặp
là việc và lập Y hợp lại để kiểm tra
việc đúng hay sai để mà tiếp tục chặng 2
là nó dừng đây thì
cái vòng lặp cơ bản nhất mà các bạn
thường ấy biết nó vòng For đúng không ạ
bí mật ngọt pho thì nó sẽ có à Mình thấy
nó có bốn điều thức như sau
Em đang coi phim mình ghi luôn trong lại
được
for này
ở
đầu tiên là cho thường hay sai bảo y này
Y cho Y = 1 chứng nặng y nhỏ hơn 10 ạ và
y + + như này à A và đây sẽ
mình sẽ đó comment chấm ra Im để im đi à
ăn thịt đây đây đề cách viết của một
vòng lặp for
em có bạn nhìn rõ rồi em ạ
thì kể cách viết này nó sẽ như sau các
bạn sẽ thấy ở cái biểu thức một này
thì nó sẽ ra khai báo thường ai xa để
khai báo giá trị ban đầu thường ai thế
biểu thức 2 ở biển thực so sánh mình sẽ
So sánh có cái biểu thức này thì biểu
thức điều kiện nếu mà cái biểu thức này
đúng thì vòng lọc sẽ tiếp tục chạy cầm
đều thức này sai thì phòng họp sẽ ngừng
a tiếp theo là biểu thức kiểu
tăng cái biểu thức này các bạn đang nhìn
thấy là nó là y + + tức là y = y + 1 đấy
ạ
là biểu biểu thức khiến thường là cái
đội thước để khiến cho cái cái vòng lặp
nó sẽ bị ngừng để ông ạ là phá vỡ vòng
lặp
khiến cho cái này sai đã sử đang một
đống ngoại cứ tăng dần dần dần dần lên
để cho nó nhận nó lớn hơn hoặc bằng 10
chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ dừng vòng lặp và
biểu thức này là biểu thức để mà chạy
khi mà vòng lặp đang chạy
Ừ đúng ạ nghĩa cái này các bạn thấy là
con pho nó sẽ gồm 44 điều thức như thế
này à
ờ thì ờ đây 1 để 2 đề 3 đề 4 này đề thi
sắc cái cái thứ tự của cái việc chạy của
vòng lọc này đấy
thì các bạn nhớ cái thứ tự chạy của vòng
lặp này thì nó sẽ từ số mấy thứ mấy ông
ạ
Ừ
mình cư
à à
đi tìm một đầy đúng ạ
có một mạch mà mình đi thẳng đây đi
à à
ở một lễ 2
E3 này và đây là 4 cả đoạn này 40 ạ thì
1234 thì theo các bạn thì nó sẽ chạy
theo thứ tự như thế nào
anh không nó chạy theo thứ tự biểu thức
như nào Chứ không phải nó sẽ in ra như
thế nào in ra như nào người ông đấy biết
hết rồi
anh nói bạn kia trả lời đúng luôn rồi
kìa 1243 ông ạ
A gọi tôi tôi đang hỏi dạng lại các bạn
thôi vì nhiều bạn mới học thì các bạn sẽ
bị nhầm sang 1234
đúng mạn trên là đúng nghĩa là nó sẽ
chạy cái đầu tiên này nó luôn chạy cái
và và chính xác chính xác Đấy là các bạn
nói 1243 cũng đúng rồi nhưng mà chưa đủ
Tại sao
ờ ờ đây
Ừ cái này chạy đầu tiên đúng không ạ Có
chạy thứ 2 để kiểm tra đúng không ạ
Ừ nếu mà cái này cái thứ hai là đúng cái
thứ hai này đúng nhá thì nó chạy đến cái
thứ tư đúng hoặc nó chạy đến cái thứ Tư
này đúng ạ nó không chạy này cái thứ ba
đó nó chạy cái thứ Tư này
khi mà chạy hết toàn bộ Cái thứ tư rồi
Nó quay lại thứ ba đúng không ạ để mà để
mà tăng giá trị hay làm gì đó nó họ để
phá vỡ vòng lặp sau đó thì nó lại quay
lại cái thứ hai đúng ạ Quay lại cái thứ
2 là nó kiểm tra xem cái lần này điều
kiện còn đúng hay không Nếu vẫn còn đúng
thì nó lại chạy tiếp thì Thứ Tư đúng ạ
Còn nếu sai thì nó dừng không ạ con Nếu
nó vẫn đúng thì nó chạy cái thứ tư so
với lại quay lại thứ ba sao lại quay thứ
hai nó sẽ không quay lại thể thứ nhất
một lần nào nữa để ông ạ A và thuận chí
Nếu giả sử ngay từ lúc đầu cài đầu tiên
cái thứ nhất chạy này không ạ Cái thứ
hai chạy mà nó đã sai ngay từ đầu rồi
đúng không ạ
thì nó sẽ không chạy đến cái thứ tư và
thứ 3 luôn đúng ạ Đây mình sẽ thử ví dụ
Các bạn xem được bạn sẽ hiểu với ví dụ
này thì mình in ra thì cứ làm các bạn
thấy từ 1 đến 9 đúng rồi đúng ạ nhưng
bây giờ giả sử mình cho một cái số ngay
từ đầu đó là một trăm nữa Ngạn thì rõ ra
điều kiện nó sai đúng không ạ bị đi nó
ra này các bạn thấy nó chẳng in ra cái
gì cả bởi việc nó có chạy được vòng lặp
đâu ạ nó không chạy đến cái đó commons
ai này không ạ ra xử mì cho đó cùng mình
dai ở ngoài như thế này thì các bạn sẽ
thấy lúc đầu khai báo y = 100 này sôi
ndai ở ngoài đó thì các bạn thấy nó sẽ
in ra y ở ngay ngoài luôn đúng không ạ
nghĩa là nó i5 100 thôi không ạ Nó không
phải là 101 nó không chạy vào đây 5 101
đúng
ạ Bây giờ mình giả sử mình đổi nó thành
từ một đêm như này chẳng hạn thì các bạn
thấy là từ 1 đến 10 không phải từ 1 đến
9 nữa tuổi việc nó
ở đoạn này nó làm như nào bạn này thì
thì chỉ đơn giản là nó in từ 1 đến 9
bằng vòng lọc
Hà
Nội Yên từ 1 đến 9 bằng màng lọc nóng
lạnh sau đó thì đến khi y = 10 thì nó
dừng nó không y bằng vòng lọc nữa nhưng
nó vẫn in ra cái giá trị cuối của y = 10
khi lại y tăng lên một ở đây đúng không
ạ Tại sao tự nhiên mình phải đề cập với
cái vụ này ở đây Bởi vì bây giờ mình sẽ
hướng dẫn các bạn qua vì kể
Vòng nào khác
Ừ đúng rồi Nãy giờ mình có để các bạn
hỏi về việc là
Ừ lần này anh không thể thay báo kiểu và
2 led
à à
anh Đợi mình tí Đợi Minh chị có con chó
Anh
Ngọc Anh nó cắn dây điện thoại
à à
thế nào
o0o
thì
các bạn ấy để
các bạn đôi khi để những cái kiểu chi
tiết nhỏ như thế thì thì các bạn sẽ hiểu
cũng là động não mà đang tập trung động
não có thử và thắc mắc như thế là tốt và
các bạn đưa ra câu hỏi nó càng tốt không
ạ bởi vì cái này là môi trường nên là
thoải mái tương tác hai chiều hơn lại bị
động ở trên trường nếu mà các bạn học
theo kiểu bị động các bạn sẽ không nhớ
kiến thức mình học chung lớp mình toàn
tương tác liên tục của thầy cô
Ê bà cũng tạo động lực cho họ cho thầy
cô thầy cô cảm thấy có mình nghe và cậu
có người tương tác nữa thì nó hơn một
Hoàng Tự kỷ không ạ
thì cái vụ mà không khai báo về và Led
ấy Thực ra là đối với ngôn ngữ khác thì
nó sẽ bị lỗi ngay nhưng mà đổ về ngôn
ngữ này thì các bạn thuế nó cái da Suite
mày nó hơi bị lỏng lẻo một tí về cái vụ
này đó là
đó là theo kiểu là đôi khi không cần
khai báo hoạt động chứa khai báo nó là
là chuỗi rồi Sao anh ấy nó sáng số thì
vẫn được vân vân vân tím mình sẽ đề cập
các bạn mình lấy vụ đấy ở đây à
anh nói chung là cái này là hạn chế về
việc là không khai báo
em cho dù là không khai báo nó vẫn sẽ
nhận như thế này các bạn thấy nó vẫn sẽ
nhận vẫn sẽ chạy đúng không ạ Không ạ
con vụ bây giờ mình sẽ khai báo nó thời
gian nó vẫn sẽ không khác gì cả các bạn
thấy kết quả là chả khác gì cả đầu nhọn
như là mình khuyên các bạn là lần sau
mình phải khai báo có dư thứ
ừ ừ
thì
tại sao khai báo trong Ford ngoài vòng
For mà vẫn dùng được nhỉ Bạn kia hỏi một
cái câu cũng rất ở được theo kiểu là bởi
vì nếu với ngôn ngữ lập trình khác thì
các bạn sẽ thấy là nó sẽ báo lỗi cái này
thì
các bạn tra tìm hiểu về Global và local
variable thì các bạn sẽ đọc và anh hiểu
về cái việc mà
anh với ngôn ngữ lập trình một vài ngôn
ngữ lập trình Thì cái này nó nó kiểu
dạng Mà mông lung lắm giống như là ra
Speed thì rõ ràng à lô bồ khai báo kiểu
như này nó vẫn tính ở Global chẳng ạ ạ
Ừ ok Nói chung mà bây bây giờ mình sẽ
anh giải thích thêm một tí kỹ về kiểu
bông hoa for này cho các bạn không hiểu
này Đầu tiên thì như mình đã nói Phòng
gặp này nó có bạn 4 điều thức đúng ạ và
nó cách nhau bởi dấu chấm phẩy như thế
này đúng không ạ
Và thậm chí nếu các bạn
Ừ nếu các bạn không Không biết thì thậm
chí là mấy cái này nó có thể để chống
Miễn sao là có để chấm phẩy đây là được
ra xử ra sự là mình sẽ xóa Dạo này đi
mình đẩy nó sang đây này bởi vì rõ ràng
là các bạn nhớ là rõ ràng là cái này thỏ
chạy một lần không ạ thì mình để nó ở
ngoài được mà cần gì phải để nó vào
trong này đúng không ạ mình để nó ra
ngoài Các bạn thấy nó vẫn Kết quả nó vẫn
thế chả gì thay đổi cả đúng ạ nghĩ em
chỉ là
ở cái đoạn này để chồng Thậm chí các
đoạn này để chống được thế lắm chị ạ tất
cả những cái này để chống Giả sử cái này
mình cũng cho nó xuống đây
Ừ cũng được các bạn sẽ thấy da
em có có phải là có phải là kiểu Hết
vòng lặp xong mình chạy cái khi
nói chung là cái để phá vỡ vọng lập thì
mình để nó ở cuối có sao đâu đúng ạ Đấy
mình chạy qua nó vẫn thế đúng ạ và từ
cái việc các bạn để ý kĩ nhé từ cái việc
mà rút gọn rút gọn Vì cái vòng lập theo
kiểu lại khai báo một lần không ạ tao
tổng là một nơi này đúng ạ Cái kiểm tra
cái kiểm tra vòng nạp chạy Tao để đương
nhiên Bắc Bộ vẫn phải có cái luôn có cái
thì kiểm tra vòng lặp còn đúng hay sai
để chạy đúng không ạ
A và
chỉ cốt để chạy này và cái thứ để cháu
vẫn còn lập tôi cho luôn ở trong lòng
lại miếng để nó quấy được không ạ từ cái
này chúng ta sẽ có vòng lặp while
em lại giống như bạn kia đã nói đúng rồi
lại đây mình sẽ có vòng lập qua à
chú
chó thì các bạn thấy là Kết quả nó như
nhau à
Ừ cái này tất cả Sao cái này là ok khai
báo một lần không ạ tao khai báo đầu
tiên ở ngoài sau đó đi Khi mà điều kiện
vẫn còn đúng đúng không ạ thì mình chạy
các thử cốt các thứ và cái cái này cái
này là cái khác và nhiều bạn dễ quên này
các bạn quên mất cái thứ để phá vỡ vòng
lặp khi mà khi mà ghi vào trong khoai
này mà nếu mà các bạn mà quên như thế
này
thì các bạn quên như thế này thì vòng
lặp này nó sẽ chạy đi chạy lại In số 1
lặp lại liên tục bởi vì rõ dai không ngờ
tăng thành ra lạc không bao giờ kiểu phá
vỡ vòng lập này và chạy đi chạy lại nếu
mà Mấy ông chạy cái này thì trang web nó
sẽ treo như thế này treo như này thì mấy
ông thấy treo này nếu phải tắt vội ngay
nhá vẫn chưa tắt luôn chọn tát thì gửi
nó chết rồi à
cho
tôi lại mở lên à Tôi xin lỗi à
ở đó như này
à à Bạn kiến thắc mắc về in xuống 10
mình mình xóa này đi được mà ạ
Ừ nhưng mà mình mình mình chưa muốn xóa
vội bởi vì ạ Tí mình sẽ giải thích về vụ
có một cái vụ nữa giống tương tự tương
tự giống như là cái vừa nãy mình nói và
vòng lặp bằng là pho thì nó cũng tương
tự giống mong là White ở điểm là nếu là
sử mà bây giờ mình cho Y = 100 được ạ
Các bạn thấy nó không in
anh làm sao mà in từ 1 đến 100 được hãy
các thử được bởi rõ ra mà 100 Nó lớn hơn
10 mất rồi nên hàng giờ nó không chạy
bằng lập luôn đúng không ạ nó không cộng
đi luôn và nó sẽ in ra ra mỗi y thôi và
bằng 100 luôn đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ đấy thì tại sao tự nhiên mình cứ phải
để cập về cái vụ là việc vòng lặp nó
không chạy thì nó sẽ in ra như nào Cái
này các bạn biết rồi mà đúng ạ Bởi vì
bây giờ mình sẽ dậy nốt các bạn về cái
vòng lặp đu White đúng ạ
mà mập duyy Tức là sao dai này nó sẽ
Tống xuống dưới
em
và nó sẽ có đủ ở trên thế này các bạn sẽ
để ý kỹ bạn sẽ thấy nó sẽ in ra 100
ý và thận Chị ơi cộng lên một để in 101
ở dưới cái vào lọ Dubai này tức là sao
đu quay này nó lại theo Thiên hướng là
nó luôn chạy ít nhất một lần cái vòng
lọc trước khi kiểm tra điều kiện nếu mà
điều kiện tự nhiên điều kiện đưa chắc
chắn sai rồi đúng không ạ Nếu điều kiện
sai thì đi nhiên nó dừng nó không chạy
vòng làm tiếp
Ừ nhưng mà ít nhất là nó chạy một lần đã
đấy các bạn thấy nó có sẽ có sự khác
biệt ở đây đúng không ạ Là là vòng mập
đây mình sẽ tổng kết lại phải ba vòng
lắp Mình vừa chỉ 3 vòng lặp này bao bằng
là cơ bản các bạn sẽ biết thêm vào mặc
Ford Liên quan à Anh về duyệt mạng nữa
nhưng mà cái đấy mình không dạy ở trong
mua Switch mình sẽ dạy ở bên pp sau vòng
lặp for thì các bạn sẽ thấy nó có bốn
biểu thức
nó sẽ biến thức đầu là biểu thức A khai
báo về Đức hai điều kiện kiểm tra điều
kiện đúng không ạ Cái thứ ba là là
cái biểu thức để phá vỡ điều kiện
thứ càng khiến cho điều kiện trở thành
sai đúng không ạ Và đều thức bốn là là
cốt chạy vòng lặp đúng không ạ Ừ cứ cho
là cốt Đi đái Con biểu thức White thì nó
sẽ khác nó sẽ chỉ gồm hai biểu thức thôi
nó sẽ là thì nó sẽ điều kiện ngay từ đầu
luôn và cốt và đương nhiên các bạn sẽ
thấy là nó sẽ Thiếu cái hai cái một cái
cái sai báo đúng ạ và một cái là phá vỡ
vòng phá vỡ điều kiện thì cái khai báo
các bạn phải khai báo ở đâu đó trước
trước cái mọc là của ai Không không phải
nằm trong vòng 1 byte đó ngoại tiếp theo
cái phá vỡ điều kiện các bạn phải nằm
luôn trong phần cốt Còn nếu không thì
điều kiện đấy sẽ chạy mãi không được
không ạ Và còn cái dwight d
em
về cơ bản thì các bạn sẽ thấy là nếu mà
viết theo kiểu như trên này thì rõ ràng
là Dubai khác gì với ye cả đúng không ạ
ạ ạ
[âm nhạc]
Ừ nhưng mà cái sự khác biệt ở đây đó là
cái for và cái Có ai như mình nói nó là
điều kiện đúng thì nó mấy chạy đúng ạ
Còn đu quay là nó sẽ chạy trước rồi nó
mới kiểm tra điều kiện đúng hạn nghĩa là
kiểu gì nó cũng sẽ chạy ít nhất một lần
ít nhất một lần không ạ
em vừa rồi mình tổng kết lại à
ô ma vòng lọc các bạn thấy à
anh có hẹn tương đối nhanh mình cảm thấy
nhanh 8:20 mới rồi
nhé bây giờ
áp dụng nó kết hợp với bài tập thì nó
mới kiểu mày ra là vấn đề không ạ Chứ lý
thuyết lý thuyết mình hạn chế lý thuyết
của bọn lý thuyết mình sẽ dậy rất ngắn
Các bạn thấy ra một tiếng mình dạy lý
thuyết sẽ nhắn à
ạ bây giờ để sao mày tập thì mình xin
phép là bây giờ sẽ kết hợp luôn và cái
cả cái input Ê bà kết hợp từ bài bố
xuống trước nữa input ướt ở xa nghĩa là
bây giờ thay vì mình gán luôn hẳn cái
dụng Red eye bằng 10 như này sẽ mình đi
thẳng vào trong cốt là mười thực ra thế
này không tốt Bởi vì bây giờ là mình
tương tác và tương tác với người khách
hàng với người dùng ở ngoài người dùng
sẽ đi để các màn hình như thế này người
dùng nhập cái gì đó sẽ in ra cái gì đó
đúng ạ thay vì rồi mình mình bắt người
xem vào cốt để nó sửa như thế này sẽ
không được đúng không ạ
à à
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ có cái là nhập
số đầu tiên ở Thôi mình cứ dậy đơn giản
trước là nhập tên của bạn chẳng hạn cái
này rất cơ bản là không ạ Chị sẽ có cái
input đi này nó khai thac này và đây sẽ
là như thế này là sự giả sử Nga nhập tên
của bạn Sau đó mình sẽ có cái nút ở đây
là kiểm tra ip à Ừ
hình ảnh kiểu nhà Okay Thi Thi ở đây ra
xử là sợ là
đó là sự là bạn nhập tên dụng là anh
hàng ạ ấn vào như thế này nó sẽ in ra
Xin chào bạn anh bạn tôi thông minh rồi
ạ chào cờ thế đấy thi lại đại khái à là
như thế nữa là mình sẽ lấy cái thứ mà
người ta đã ngập rồi kết hợp với một cái
câu gì đó của mình bán nữa Đúng là một
cái chuỗi gì đó của mình và nữa thì lấy
cái thứ mà người ta đã nhập thì mình sẽ
thông qua việc là lấy có thể có thể theo
nhiều cách một là theo thẻ input như thế
này Nhưng mà nếu mà trong một form có
nhiều cái thẻ input này quá thành nhà
lại thành sai đúng không ạ
cho nên có cách thứ hai là lấy theo ID
bởi ID nó duy nhất
Ừ thì mình sẽ thường ai lấy theo ID mình
sẽ đặt tên nó lại input là
Ừ ông kia vẫn hỏi thôi Tại sao không
dùng ghép cốt à
Ừ ông nào đó trả lời của tôi có lấy được
39 phút tên ở Lạng Sơn hay là tên như
thế này à ờ ờ
à à
Ờ Ờ
mình mình để lấy được cái cái cái này về
thì mình sẽ là nó của mình
Chấm ghét almond bye đi này
hóa hoặc là các bạn gõ ngày xong rồi Tát
ra xong rồi đi chữ y ngay là đường Đấy
in phút
tên này à ba chấm ba lô này
Ừ nếu mà chấm baru tất cả lấy giá trị nó
bên mình sẽ đặt một cái vọng à Một cái
biến và biến tên như thế này Đấy
sau đó thì mình đo comment chấm right
này in ra thật sự là xin chào bạn xong
ngồi nội tên mà như hai đứa bạn
bên mình chạy nhé
tải lại này các bạn thấy thử cao nó đã
bị lỗi mà mình sẽ bị lôi xuống dòng các
bạn cho bạn dễ nhìn nhé
thì
các bạn thấy nó đang bị lỗi Tại sao em
chưa kịp Bấm cái nút em còn chưa điền
cái gì cả đúng không ạ Tại sao nó hiển
thị ra luôn cái Xin chào bạn thì gì đó
như này cái giờ em giả sử em gõ cho em
bấm nút thì được không ạ Chả có gì cả
thì ở đây bài toán khó là như thế nào nó
là
Ờ Ờ
mình cần Không cần hiển thị ra cái Xin
chào luôn ngay từ khi vào trang web mà
mình cần khi bấm vào cái nút này nó mấy
chạy về đoạn nó mới lấy cái thứ mình đã
nhập đúng ạ Rồi rồi hiển thị ra đủ Xin
chào đúng không ạ
Ừ thì thì cái cái việc khi bấm vào nút
thì nó mới chạy cái gì đó thì mình sẽ có
khái niệm là on click như thế này và
nhà mình có thể có luôn toàn bộ code này
Vào trong này như này cũng được nhưng mà
các bạn hãy việc mất đi toàn bộ cốt vào
cái này để chạy như thế này thì trông nó
bị xấu khó đọc cũng như là kiểu nó rối
quá đúng ạ Cái kiểu đấy cửa in life ạ ra
Switch in life thì thường mà chẳng hay
áp dụng đấy thường là mình sẽ gọi đến
cái hàm ở đó đây mình sẽ gọi đến hàn là
hàm à in ra ạ in ra như thế nào đó thì
để gọi với cái Hà Min da này mình sẽ tạo
ra một cái Hàn là Hà Min ra
thế này ở đó 30 sống ở như thế này mình
chạy thử anh này bấm vào này đó thì nó
mới xin chào bạn anh không ạ Ok không ạ
thì các bạn hiểu chưa ạ à
Ê mấy ông ấy giờ Cãi nhau cái gì đấy
ở tập trung là tốt chút nào hay ở cái
này dễ quà ấy mấy ông chuyển qua ngồi
chém gió trên kinh xác của tôi đúng
không ạ
à à
ở đây Các bạn thấy à
Ừ
cái cái cái việc thứ nhất đấy đó làm Nếu
các bạn để ý kĩ là mình nãy rồi còn anh
làm sai cơ mình đang làm sai
Ừ cái sai ở đây đó là mình đã từng dặn
Các bạn về vụ là mua khi có input
Ừ thì phải luôn nằm trong thẻ home Các
bạn nhớ không ạ Không bao giờ có trường
hợp và để input đơn lẻ như thế này đúng
không ạ mình phải luôn để nó nằm trong
thẻ form đấy thì bây giờ ra sự mình có
thể for đây đúng không ạ
thì mình tống mà thôi ông ạ tổng cài bút
cả postin vào trong thấy for này Thực ra
là đóng thì iPhone rồi mình không cần PR
nữa cũng được chạy này đó Bây giờ mình
sẽ là chào bạn anh ấy ấn vào này đúng ạ
Được rồi đúng không ạ Các bạn thấy được
nhưng mà ở đây mình nặng khó chịu một tí
anh khó chịu mới được mà ok Bây giờ em
muốn nhập tên bạn khác luôn em lại mất
công tải lại sang nhà hiển thị ra đúng ạ
Chị vừa Khanh Vì như thế Mình muốn thị
ngay ở dòng ở dưới giống như vừa nãy đó
mình hiển thị luôn ở dừa như này là xin
chào bạn A B C thay vì cậu nó ghi đè lên
toàn bộ HTML cũ của mình để mà hiển thị
ra mỗi cái dòng chữ không ạ thì cái này
mình sẽ không dùng đó còn dai nữa và lần
này mình sẽ phải như thế nào mình sẽ tạo
ra một cái đíp ở dưới này phòng cười
span ở dưới một cái thiệp P ở dưới chẳng
hạn Vân Vân ở trong một thứ ở dưới một
cái ô để mà hiển thị ra xin chào Cái gì
đó đúng ạ Chị sẽ có một cái đít này Đấy
và mình sẽ gọi ai đi là cáo kết quả sản
nào đó và bây giờ mình dậy in kết quả
vào trong cái này chứ không phải đâu cần
ra à sẽ ghi đè an toàn bộ HM cũ nữa thì
nó sẽ lại ghét em mình body này và đây
sẽ là kết quả này
và đây sẽ là mình sẽ có khái niệm mà
chuẩn inner HTML bằng đoạn chỗ như thế
này à
em có cốt kiểu này thì ra tôi thấy nó
hơi bị ạ Đấy Tôi Lùi một tát cho mấy ông
nhìn
à à
ở lại mấy ông nhìn có thể nó bị xuống
dòng một tí hai chữ hi vọng chữ đủ to do
mấy ông đi à
Á
đù to chưa ạ ạ
Ừ Thì bây giờ mình sẽ nhập dụng nhập anh
nản ấn đây Xin chào bạn anh Các bạn thấy
nó vừa thì đi ra Nhưng mà trước ngoan
đúng không ạ chớp nhoáng luôn tại sao ạ
bị ẩn anh này ấn phát nữa này nó thì chị
ra xong rồi nó lại cha luôn tại sao nó
lại nó lại trang như vừa rồi là bởi vì
nếu mà các bạn để nó nằm trong lại phom
kết hợp với nó là bất Tần như này thì nó
sẽ Các bạn nhớ bọn Nếu mà cái nút như
này không thôi thì thay của nó sẽ bằng
sắm ít
hay nó sắp ít tất cả nó sẽ gửi cái phone
này lên gửi for mà lên đồng nghĩa việc
là nó lạy cha mất rồi đóng mặt nó mà
mình cần trang bang vẫn phải giữ nguyên
ở đấy đúng không ạ chào vẫn giữ nguyên
rồi đấy thì mình sẽ khái niệm nó bắt Tần
Nghĩa này là hiểu nút này chuyển dạ Nó
là cái nút thôi nó không một tác dụng
gửi form lên ở bề mà nó lại tra đúng
không ạ Mình tả lại xa phát nữa này gọi
cho anh này ấn vào này đó là sự gọi chữ
Long đấy Ấn vào như này được đúng không
ạ Các bạn hoàn toàn giống như và nãy
mình nói là có thể in ra nhận cái ví dụ
là
các
bạn thật là thông minh
DK lời đã bê cả đó đấy
A
bkl ở
Việt kiều nhé
ở đó
Ừ thôi nãy hơi bậy rồi
đấy đúng không ạ Anh Tuấn chẳng ạ nhập
được cả có dấu nhé đó
Ừ
Ok đúng rồi đúng không ạ
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là à
ở đây đây đây mới chỉ là cơ bản về việc
là
lấy cái thứ mà mình đã ngập trong cái Ôi
nút cho in ra dọn rất cơ bản chồng kẹo
Halloween các bạn học vậy nhưng nhưng mà
bây giờ mày bắt ở nâng cao lên một tí
thôi bắt đầu kiểm tra không ạ bây giờ
Thái Bình nhập tên sẽ nhập con số thì đó
sao mình is a nó chẵn hay lẻ thôi chẳng
nào thì sẽ liên lạc
nhập số cho này Đây là input số
em kiểm tra
chẵn lẻ
để chẵn lẻ để in ra này Ừ kệ gì bạn ạ
Bây giờ mình sẽ let
số bằng cho comment
bettermann Bye bye bút số đúng không ạ
trên phút
0.3 lô này mình sẽ ít số phần trăm hay
bằng bằng không là kiểm tra xem số số
đây chia cho 2 lấy dư Nếu mà dư không
tất cả số chẵn không ạ Mình sẽ là đó của
mình chậm ra à Ghét em ân bye đi này kết
quả này à
cho
nhtm là
đây là số chẵn
eo ở đây để số lẻ đúng không ạ
ừ ừ
32 Trả này nè này chả này ok không ạ
Nhưng ở đây Thực ra là nó có tí hơi sai
sai nếu mà các bạn làm như thế này là sự
3.5 lại ra số lẻ thì buồn cười quá thì
các bạn sẽ có thể là yeo ít ở đây này
đây sẽ cậu bằng một số lẻ còn em nữa Ở
đây là
đây là số nguyên tố ở Ngạn anh em đề số
thập phân là không ạ thập phân
thân dưới đây không phải là số nhà mạng
cũng được tùy mấy ông
anh ở đây Tôi đang nghiệp chữ mà mọi thì
đây ở đang số thập phân Thì có sai được
không ạ Nếu các bạn muốn chắc chắn nó số
thì các bạn để nó là number này à
anh hả
là số âm bị vẫn là chẵn lẻ được mà không
ạ Còn nếu các bạn muốn kiểm tra việc
bắt lỗi số các bạn so sánh nó với không
ạ Các bạn so sánh nó với không Nếu mà
lớn không thì thì thì in ra Còn nếu
không thì ngược lại báo lỗi không ạ
Ừ cái việc báo lỗi thì đây mình sẽ tiện
nó luôn
tránh sử là đây mấy ông đang thấy đó là
tôi tôi muốn là
áo kiểu
in ra cái cái số thập phân này nhưng mà
riêng với số thập phân thì tôi sẽ có màu
khác không ạ sửa đây 3.5 thì các bạn sẽ
thấy nói nào số thập phân nhưng mà riêng
in số thập phân thì sẽ có màu khác thì
mình sẽ Style này color này sẽ đổi nó
thành màu đỏ đi à
à à
nghe 3.5 đấy
ở đó
Ừ nhưng mà chính vì khi mà chỉnh Speed
này xong thì có nhớ có vẻ là nó sẽ không
chạy lại nó sẽ không Chạy lại Cái vụ sai
nữa Nhưng mà đồng thời thì do Style rõ
khi đề CS lên cái đít này rồi thành đạt
Deep này sẽ giữ nguyên mòi đúng không ạ
Các bạn có thể để nó ở đây là sự đây là
màu đen nếu mà các bạn muốn để mặc định
đúng không ạ sẽ như này à
ừ ừ
ở
đó rồi luôn các bạn sẽ thế là ra Swift
có thể làm được cái này nó không đoán
lại cha chạy chạy Các bạn ơi Không nói
lại cha gì cả nó sẽ lập tức thì chị ra
luôn tức thì luôn cho các bạn thấy
ờ ờ
Ok nhưng mà bài thế này vẫn dễ quá cũng
chỉ lại ít theo thôi đưa mình đưa nó vào
cái bài hôm trước mà mình đã làm bạn nhớ
bài về
Ừ mình mà là bạn hôm trước nhé
A Tính số ngày trong tháng ạ đúng không
ạ
A Tính số ngày trong tháng để mày đi làm
cái gì đó đúng không ạ là sửa nhé này đi
thì hôm trước có bạn cũng hỏi mình cái
vụ Tại sao các bạn in ra không được để
mình giải thích các bạn dịch vụ này
chưa bao giờ sử mình nhập tháng 10 năm
nữa không ạ
à à
Em
in both tháng
anh ở đây là bà nhập Nam đi à
à à
khi
cha Xóa cái này thôi
Tháng này
Đây là
em
kiểm tra xem có tối đa
bao nhiêu ngày
ăn chơi ạ ạ
Ừ
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ xuất Cai đúng không
ạ Các bạn hôm trước nhở vụ xích Tây rồi
mình sẽ So sánh Nếu mà tháng 1 xong rồi
tháng 3 tháng 5 7 8
top 10 12 thì mình sẽ cho
mình sẽ phải báo trước ở đây Tết này như
này đi và mình sẽ cho ngày bằng 31
subject như thế này
tương tự Thế chị sẽ có là
a46
29 11 Đông ạ
đi xe 30 ngày
ạ sau đó thì cay 2 thì mình sẽ có đoạn
điệp khúc gì đó
anh hỏi mình lười có cái đoạn này quá
cho bỏ qua đi mặc định bằng 28 đi sự thế
không ạ Black từ đây những lần này mình
sẽ cho một cái phô đi và khi mình nhập
sai chọn Vân Vân đó sẽ là cậu này bằng
sai cả đại khái như thế sau nhà mình sẽ
cho comment
chấm chemin body kết quả này
chấm innerhtml bằng
số này là hai chấm này
a cộng với ngày này chẳng hạn như này
không ạ chạy thử nhé
Cô thích gà nếu như này mình bỏ qua năm
với Chán không cần quan tâm năm đó lại
khá như thế Bấm này xuống này là sai đấy
hai số này vẫn là sai một số loại vẫn là
sai này Tại sao lại vẫn vẫn là sai
Ừ
cái quan trọng ở đây là sai là đúng sai
là đúng Tại sao bởi vì à Cái Khánh này
nó lấy về nó đang là chuỗi không phải là
số các bạn nó sau sàng lòng với số chứ
sao nó sai được bên mình chưa đổi nó ra
là Trỗi ngay nhá cho mình nhập lại số 1
đấy đó các bạn thấy là nó đang so sánh ở
đây nó sẽ khác với cái so sánh mà mình
mình mới dậy các bạn mới dậy các bạn thì
mình mới chị So sánh các bạn về việc là
bằng Bằng nghe vậy thôi Băng Băng như
thế này tức là giá trị đâu nhau thôi ra
sửa đây mình sẽ trải nghiệm là ba bằng
bằng bằng 3 đương nhiên các bạn thấy ở
đây nó sẽ là Chu tất cả là đúng đúng ạ
Nhưng mà nếu trong trường hợp 3 bằng
bằng chuỗi 3 như này thì ở chùa Côn ạ
thế này hỏi qua một tí mấy ông trả lời
nhanh cho tôi mấy câu này
D3 bằng bằng chuỗi 3 thì nó là chuông
iPhone
ừ ừ
Ừ ông kia iPhone còn ghi sai như thế này
đậu xanh
ừ ừ
thì
nó vẫn là Chu thôi nó vẫn là Chu nó vẫn
đúng cái bằng bằng này nó chỉ so sánh
giá trị giá trị của nó hai cái đối với
máy tính giá trị nó bằng nhau đều bằng 3
cả nó sẽ đều biến lại thành bằng ba gác
bây giờ chính vì như thế thì nên mới có
so sánh kiểu như thế này mới là phô này
đấy
ý nghĩa là khi so sánh như này thì thì
nó sẽ So sánh kết hợp với các kiểu giá
trị nữa
cái trong trường hợp này thì kệ 3 3G
băng này để mà ám chỉ lại phải giống hệt
nhau nghĩa là chỉ có trường hợp mà
anh giống hệt nhau theo kiểu như này nó
mới đúng này điều ạ thế này nói đúng rồi
còn nếu mà so sánh nó với kiểu giá trị
khác kiểu giờ chị chuỗi như thế này nó
cho chắn sẽ lỗi
thì nó sẽ biến thành phone không ạ Thi
Thế nên mới có vụ ở đây đó là cái xích
cây này nó so sánh không phải bằng hai
dấu bằng mà nói so sánh bằng ba dấu bằng
nên là cái tháng này đang là chuỗi khi
mà còn nhập vào kể cả các bạn để thay nó
nằm bờ nhưng mà ra sức hút không hiểu
đâu Nó vẫn sẽ hiểu cái tháng này là
chuỗi nên nó so sánh 3 giờ bằng với tất
cả mấy cái trường hợp này thì hướng
nghĩa là nó sẽ không thỏa mãn mà nhảy
vào Cái phô rồi không ạ Các bạn thấy nó
đang nhảy vào đây phô như này thành biến
thì sai hết đúng không ạ thì bây giờ
trong trường hợp này thì mình nếu mà 1
số 1 là bạn sẽ phải cho toàn bộ Cái này
thành Trỗi người gà cái kiểu như thế thì
không không nên làm lắm mà vì nó không
có vẻ nghe nghe có vẻ không hợp lôgích
làm đúng không ạ
Cách thứ hai là các bạn sẽ phải hết cái
chỗ này thành số nó sẽ phạt như thế này
in thế này
ở đây nó sẽ có 2 cách để mà ép một cái
lại fast in 2 carapace Plus ca sĩ lf nó
hàng số nguyên và tạt flash thì em nói
anh số thực đương nhiên là nếu là số
nguyên thì bà flash thì nó vẫn thành số
nguyên khối với nó sống yên mà bọn nó
không có thêm phẩy làm sao đâu ạ
đi đái nếu mà ông làm như thế này nó mới
đúng đấy
một này đó đưa đúng đấy đây giải thích
cho bạn nào hôm trước bạn bởi vì hôm
trước mình mình bảo các bạn làm bài về
nhà ấy thì các bạn chỉ cần làm đã ra
Swift thôi các bạn không cần làm own
food ngay như hôm trước có bạn cũng ngồi
làm à Ôi nút như này xong rồi bạn dùng
xích cây bạn đấy bảo là chẳng in ra cái
gì cả đúng mặt của vì rõ ràng là bạn đấy
chưa hiểu về cái cơ chế in bút là nhập
vào là chuỗi thì bạn sao sàng xích cây
Chắc chắn là nó chẳng ra cái quả gì cả
nó chẳng ở cây nào bạn đây cũng không
cho bé iPhone luôn bạn nghĩ là cô chứ
chả ngon luôn Chạy không Giờ có chuyện
đấy phô thành ra là không in gì cả Không
ạ à Thế à Giờ Rồi ạ ạ
ở đây là con người chưa chải đấy
khi con người chạy rồi luôn phải có cái
địa phủ để biết được lúc nào mình sai
không ạ Giống kiện trai các thôi à
có mấy cái vụ mà có bạn đang ngồi đùa
Cái vụ mà cộng xong rồi - như kia mình
sẽ thử bạn ấy đang
ờ ờ
anh đi đây
Ừ để tối nay gọi cho mấy ông thứ là mấy
ông Nếu mà Mấy ông để trĩ hôm trước tôi
hỏi mấy cái bài tập ở trên à à
3 cách để bồi
Ừ thì à
Ừ Thì Thôi ca làm mấy ông đã có thể
kopkop luôn cả cái cốt ở trên Tách cái
bồ đấy để mấy ông chạy được ở trên trình
duyệt luôn thử cho mình xem nhé Mấy ông
inspect này
hôm nay
ở nhà Ông mở con sôi lên này đã chạy
được luôn này à
ở Facebook thích để cùng tôi vào trong
trình các bài tập của tôi cho mấy ông
chạy Thượng
Ừ cái tặng Trời Sài sai không có tâm
không
Ừ hình như là riêng ông trường hợp Đúng
là trường hợp sai nó phản hồi lâu hơn
thế bạn
ở đây Cốc Cốc này
à à
ở đó chú chú ngon không ạ
vì có cô tiên
phone Ok Phone
chị đã đúng không nó cũng phải làm như
thế này mà
Có thai mấy ông cậu cối Gõ lại hoặc mấy
ông ngồi đoán xem cốc đấy như nào đấy
mẹo thôi Tôi vừa tự dùng chính bài tập
của tôi thì em ạ
ở ngọn nhà con nách chính mày Thuận dạy
cách lách trên bài tập của mình à
Ừ thì nói chung là tôi vừa dậy các bạn
về việc là
dùng ra Speed chạy được như thế nào ở
trên chính trình duyệt đó ngọn cái con
xô này nó cái để chạy ra suýt mà mà để
hiển thị lỗi nếu mà ra Switch của j sai
nữa
thì tiếp theo là
gì tương tự Thế vừa rồi có bạn tranh thủ
nói luôn về cái vụ là cái vụ ra Swift nó
bị yếu yếu về cái kiểu kiểu dữ liệu của
nó tất cả chỗ nào có thể nhảy sang số
cũng như ngược lại các bạn không để ý kĩ
là rõ ràng xuống ngày ở đây nó đang là
số à đúng không ạ Các bạn ý kỹ không ạ
gỡ ra là tôi đang dạy mấy ông là cây
từ cách đây xuống ngày của tôi đang ở số
màn không ạ Xuống ngày 31 Mà tại sao nó
có thể nối với cái chuỗi để in ra thành
31 được đúng ạ
ngõ ra và cái này đang hết nó thành
chuỗi rồi cậu nó được với nhau đúng ạ và
Chính vì cái việc nó tiện tiện nhé cũng
là bất tiện theo kiểu là nó sinh ra
những cái lỗi rất là dị trả Sự giống như
là thế này có ông vừa nói ở ở kia hội
nhưng tôi vẫn thích nó lại ai giờ sửa à
ngắm trường hợp 3
cộng với chuỗi 3 thì nó lại ra thành 33
trắng ạ
Anh đấy xong lại - 3 thìa sẽ 30 ạ
Ừ đúng ạ nhưng mà - như này nó vẫn sẽ là
30 ạ
Ừ đúng ạ Nhưng mà nếu mà 3 - Trỗi 3 rồi
cộng với 3 như này
gì đấy
hai thí mấy ông sẽ Cậu thấy nó sẽ
quan trọng về quan trọng thứ nhất là
việc Ép kiểu cho nó
và cả thứ tự của cái chạy nữa không thì
nó sẽ là
thì rõ ràng là cái này nó khác với cái
khi cây kế toán mình đừng học cái mà đổi
chỗ cho nhau là khoán vị đã làm cái gì
đấy nhưng mà ông chỉ việc đổi chỗ số cho
nhau tự nhiên thấy giá trị có thay đổi
hẳn như thế này đúng không ạ
Ừ thì nó Lũng Nhai
cha mẹ ông hiểu gì tôi đang muốn nó ạ
ở lại và đây mà ông thấy đang lũ thì tôi
xin phép cho mày không lúa thẳng qua
những cái ảnh này tôi mới tải về
số bài toán toán học ở trong g switch
ở đây
số xổ chuỗi 5 - 3 = 2 này nếu mà chửi
năm cộng 13 thì bằng 33 này
một chuỗi 5 - chuỗi 4 thì bằng một này
ý nghĩa hàm chỉ ta lúc lúc vì nó là
đề tài - nó
ở bảng - cả chuỗi với chuỗi nó lại ra số
đúng ạ
một chuỗi - về số uống thì nó ra số rồi
Chỗ ấy với chuỗi lòng ra số này nhưng mà
chuỗi cộng với chuỗi thì nó lại ra chỗ
này đấy
A1 loa như thế này
Em hãy cái tôi vừa đề cập này
i5 + - X5 - + X thì nó sẽ 50,5 này đúng
ạ ạ
à à
cho nên là nếu vào chuẩn là mấy ông sẽ
phải ép kiểu hết cho nó thành kiểu số
trước khi cộng trừ nhân chia với nó à
nhân chia thì không ra đâu nhẹ nhân chia
để nó không bị ép ở dưới nó sẽ cho nó số
rồi những hoa còn cộng trừ của nó thì nó
sẽ là nó sẽ có khái niệm là auto
Converse thì ông sẽ biết phải tiện khái
niệm đấy họ thụ convert và tự động tự
động đổi đổi kiểu dữ liệu thì nên là mấy
ông phải S chịu cho nó thành số luôn với
nhau rồi mới cộng trừ nhân chia cộng trừ
với nó đều ạ
khi con Cả thêm vụ này nữa Cái vụ này
cũng là kiểu dữ liệu của nó nó hơi bị
đau não Lỡ chị ở chỉ nốt
ừ ừ
ờ ờ Nếu mà số mà nó lớn quá nó dễ bị làm
trò này sau đó thì nếu mà 0,5 + 0,1 =
0,6 thì đúng nhưng nếu 0,1 + 0,2 = = 0,3
thì sai cái này không phải mỗi + 0,2 Tôi
nhớ không lầm đó bằng 0,2
9999 thi ấy bởi 0,1 đối với da Suite thì
nó nó không hẳn là bằng 0,1 đậu không
phải 999 gì đấy
chị thôi tiếp theo của một loạt ở dưới
này nữa ví dụ Giả sử là các bạn nhớ vợ
lại 3 giờ bang là so sánh á
các kiểu dữ liệu phải đúng đúng không ạ
Nhưng nếu xu + chu + chu
anh nói so sánh như thế này là đúng bởi
vì chu + chu này convert thành số 2 mất
rồi hai cộng với chu nữa bằng 3 Nên lúc
đấy nó bằng luôn ba cái kẹo thế
Em ở chỗ nào Cái này nó bay não nó chỉ
cho mày không xem qua thôi Tìm mấy ông
hiểu việc là ra Suite nó nó bị khác với
nhiều ngôn ngữ lập trình khác
với việc nó bay não
khi con cả cái nữa cơ nhìn thôi chứ
nghĩa cây lúa đồi núi
Ừ ok Nói chung là vừa rồi là
chị Xuka là hôm nay đã nhảy là phải dậy
cả vòng lọc kết hợp với ạ i10 input đấy
nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là tôi chỉ dậy đến
ngưỡng như này thôi mà ông có gì về làm
bài tập nhá về làm bài tập và bài tập sẽ
là tại tôi sẽ cho mấy ông xem qua bài
tập
mở bài bài hôm nay sẽ có hai cái tôi nhớ
có câu Sao
xe tải
em lấy
Anh à Hôm nay tôi ngồi chưa dậy khỏi
mạng cơ Ừ tí thôi sẽ thì tôi ra bài gì
không đề cập về cụ mạng đi
Ừ thì tôi sẽ giao trong bài tập riêng
vậy
ở
những đại khái như thế thì tôi sẽ có bài
tập cho mèo ông Còn bây giờ thì ạ tôi
chia sẻ
ở
đầu tiên là tôi có cái đường Linh này
đường link để mà nó đoạn CF
đoạn cốt xét
khẩu nó có giao diện Khá là đẹp cho tôi
gửi cho ông bé ông ấy ông Thắng khác à
Á và một cái nữa là
có một cái trang này nếu mà những ông
nào thích thế tìm hiểu về cái vụ hack
khủng thì tôi thấy Trang này Đề cập rất
là ổn
Ừ Kệ cha mày ạ là trang giải thích về
các hack khủng các thứ
và vì sau tôi sẽ dạy cho mấy ông về xss
giống như và này có bạn để cập đã cả vụ
FBI lesson
22 cái đấy tôi sẽ dạy các bạn
Ừ đúng
Ừ cái cái xăng này mấy ông thể vào
ạ bấm bấm bấm bấm các thứ mà ông xem
cách cách người ta giải thích giải thích
tại sao Hay phết
Ừ
nó đưa như bằng tiếng Anh rồi tự nhiên
bằng tiếng Anh với ông thông cảm không
phải bằng tiếng Việt được
Tại nó còn khuya là mấy ông bấm vào đâu
hay các thứ nó sẽ bị như nào nữa hay cực
Ừ nếu có thể xem qua nếu Mấy ông không
hiểu thì ạ về sau tôi sẽ giải thích
trong mấy ông ít nhất là mấy cái đầu này
còn mấy cái á mấy cái dưới này thì tôi
thấy à
em
không có phải là mình gặp thường xuyên
đi
làm cho đỡ giải thích người hôm sau điều
mà
à À đúng rồi không phải không phải không
phải 299 đúng rồi không phải
3000 kia đúng vậy Cơm mình nhớ nhầm đấy
Nói chung là đại khái là đối về đối với
da Phi kể 0,1 Mình nhớ không phải một nó
sẽ không phải là 0,1 hoàn toàn bảo nó
lại khó phải phải đón sau nữa
A và cái cuối cùng thì à
Hồi trước ở tôi từng tra và cái vụ này
vào tôi chia sẻ cho sinh viên của tôi về
cái vụ là xem thông tin dòng máy
để xem thông tin dòng mà đối với Intel
rồi nhá thì mấy ông Để ý kỹ ở Thường nay
có Y5 do ngồi gạch ngang lưng rồi nó
xong rồi số là sau mấy ông chẳng hiểu Nó
là gì ông ạ thì thì mới ông xem qua về
cách ở đây thì y52 y thì ấy là tên dòng
CPU này sau đó thì sổ ngay cái số tiếp
theo ấy
ý là kệ thế thế hệ của nó là thế hệ 7
hay thế dụ ở Lý Core I5 số 17 20m này
thì 77 rất là thế hệ 7 này và cái chữ
cuối thì để thể hiện xe mà nó là giọng
gì đây Cái chữ cuối của nó
cho mình nhớ là có chứ có cái dài thì
Cái chữ cuối
ở đây giải thích ý nghĩa của ký tự cuối
của tên này ví dụ là
Ừ nếu mà mày Ông
mua bây giờ chưa mua laptop hoặc là giả
sử về sau muốn mua lắp tội nữa đúng
không ạ thì mày ông phải biết được ý
nghĩa của nó ngồi mình nhớ là tiết kiệm
pin
đây U này nó sẽ hợp cho ông nào thích
kiểu máy tính có pin trâu
thường ai làm được văn phòng hơn
Còn nếu mà Mấy ông muốn ngon đấy Cái
chích ngon thường ai chip nó liên quan
đến chị mời này chị sẽ ngon này
lại mày không thể đọc qua và ý nghĩa của
các loại Chip có thứ
thời này không có cái thôi mà có bài
đăng này thì không có hát về hát quy đâu
Ừ đúng rồi có thể thế hệ sau này đưa có
thêm một vài cái dòng chip nữa Bài này
bài cũ rồi nhưng mà ý tôi thì về quy tắc
ghi của nó thì nó vẫn thế đối mặt thì
mời ông có thể đọc kỹ hôn chứ mấy ông
đừng có nghĩ à Mấy cái tên này thì mình
cái tên này nó không gọi nghĩa gì cả
cái tên này đều có ý nghĩa của nó và mấy
ông cần phải tra và mấy ông đừng có đánh
giá việc làm y cao nhất thì là ngon ngất
nhá đôi khi là i5 thế hệ 7 nó còn ngon
hơn cả i7 thế hệ 3 thế 4 thì gì vậy cơ
Thế nên là mấy ông phải xem thế hệ chứ
đừng có xe mỗi về cái tên dòng của sẽ
peu đúng không ạ
em có con gì thế hệ luôn là nên thế 3
đổi lên nhé và còn chích thì đương nhiên
cám chip dòng càng cao thì đương nhiên
nó sẽ càng khỏe nhưng mà như tôi đã nói
nếu mà thế hệ của nó thấp thì thì đôi
khi ở cái hàng mày i5 Thế Hệ 9 có khinh
vẫn ngon hơn trả nặng thế
anh đấy đấy về
trả chị qua cho mấy ông mà làm việc cách
mua máy tính bây giờ
Ừ ok tra ạ hết cái thứ rồi mới chia sẻ
được mấy ông rồi tạm thời thay thế
à à
Ừ thôi mấy ông kia lại đang bị đi sâu có
cả xung nhịp với số nhân tiểu đường mấy
mấy cái người mà không phải luôn công
nghệ thì tra chưa biết qua mày cái đấy
đâu Tôi đang chỉ hướng dẫn cho mấy ông
này việc mua 1 con laptop để mà để mà
khoa học tập học tập chắc là mấy ông học
tập thì cũng nhiều đấy nhà mà chơi game
thì ạ chơi mấy game giống mức độ nhẹ thì
méo càng không cần phải quan tâm về việc
là à
khi các yếu tố chip nhân hai cặp đồ họa
lắm ví dụ là sự chơi ll chơi
FIFA không nặng lắm nhỉ cái kiểu thế
hỗ trợ cho ta độ thấp nhất cho CS Go để
còn cân nhắc mình tí à
Ừ ừ thì mày Ông mua mày để mày lập trình
ở nhặn thì mày Ông không cần phải cấu
hình nặng không cần phải card đồ họa
sự thực là chỉ cầm thêm một tí hát
hồ thì nên SD mở lên nó mượn này ra mình
nên ở trên 8GB này ra bây giờ thì ra bây
giờ mà Mấy ông còn bún đi chắc chịu
không ạ Đấy
có thẩm mỹ lợn Còn mấy bạn mua về máy về
chỉ để mà
xem phim mấy bạn nữ rồi ạ thì chỉ cần
máy tính nhẹ pin trâu chạy được mấy cái
tác vụ văn phòng Ninh Thuận còn về cốt
thì các bạn thì yên tâm mà máy các bạn
mà mở được cái note á đấy thì nó sao nó
mở được cái sắp ai-tek với nó rất là nhẹ
mấy bạn thì chắc chắn hiển nhiên mở rồi
các trình duyệt rồi thì sẽ về các bạn
cút cút quét phải rất vô tư đúng không ạ
web vô từ Còn nếu mà các bạn cốt chanh
những cái kiểu cần giả lập gồm như Cốt
khi các bạn mua máy Windows mà các bạn
muốn cốt iOS phải giả lập IOS chẳng hạn
thì đương nhiên là sẽ phải thêm thêm RAM
à à
cho tôi khuyên mấy ông nghỉ nên mua 1
con laptop hơn là một con con máy tính
cảm nhận máy tính bảng bởi vì mấy ông
theo ngành Công nghệ thông tin về mail
nên đi ra ngoài nhiều hơn mang mày Anh
công ty trừ khi công ty ông tài trợ cho
một cái
khi con không thì mình nên cốt như kiểu
à mà bị mang lại nó vẫn tiện hơn
A
stardrive hết đặt mà nói rồi nha
hỗ trợ toàn bộ những câu hỏi các bạn
mình sẽ ghép buổi trao trả lời nhé
từ hôm nay trao tặng 10 như thế thôi
chào các bạn
ừ ừ